when you're young you're asked
what you want to do but before
knowing what I'm going to do I
would like to know where I want
to be
so that's me that was  really a dream
since I was little to do this
world tour finally really who doesn't or who
doesn't dream of traveling like that to do
lots of countries to meet lots of
people and yeah I like that I
still accumulated  a few miles in
distance is between 15 and 20 thousand
I arrived first in spain after I
did portugal I went along the
African coast and there I arrived in the
caribbean which after I arrive in greenland
where I  stayed a year then after I
did what is called the northwest passage
so for part of the atlantic
to arrive in the pacific by the
by the north of america in fact
then the trip it will be  finish when
we're back in france
i'm a little particular no sense where
i have a lot of friends but i really like
myself retro  uver alone to be
alone massaged it's great what it's
really great
eagle accompanied by monique
I dreamed of having a hen even before
having my boat
so I had inquired
with experts in France we m  she said
impossible if she's stressed she
can't lay monique I found in the
canaries and provisions on the boat
momo made me an egg and their cravings in
28 days we hung 25 so as much to say that
she is rather  comfortable corp baic
monique we are we are curious and we
wanted to know how things are going to
have our own opinion
I actually like finding myself
in situations that are a little bit critical and
relying only on me and that's  really
very interesting
this wintering were caught in the
ice
you wonder what you are doing there what
really
you only want one thing is that we come and
get it there are even times but I
am selling I will give my boat I
Pay my whole life for like sort of
the deal after the next day  main well the
sun is back the wind has calmed down
monique has laid an egg and life is
starting again what